hi there today we're looking at
mastering atari goat chess and shogi by
planning with a learned model by yulian
street visor and people generally from
deep mind so this paper is an extension
to alpha zero the kind of famous
algorithm that learned to play go and
chess simply by playing itself and the
kind of cool thing about this model is
is that it has a learned environment
model so what does this mean usually if
you have a game such as chess I believe
there's a picture of chess down here if
you have a game such as chess and you
want to learn to play it you need to
know that kind of the rules of chess
right so in chess you have rules like
the pawn can move two or one right the
bishop can move diagonally and so on
similarly in shogi or go here you know
where you can place the stones and when
you win everything is clearly defined so
what you can do is actually you can you
can plan right you can now think of okay
if I do if I do this opening right
my opponent could do either this or this
or you know this and for each of the
three moves I I'll have response so if
if they do they move this pawn I'll go
for it like a gambit here and if they
move this pawn then I can you know move
on something like this right so what in
essence what you have is a tree search
so you start out with the state you're
currently in right and then your
opponent oh sorry this should be your
the state you're currently in your
opponent has the option of performing
any one of these moves let's say there
are three moves and then from each of
these three moves you again have the
option of performing any of these moves
and the coupe the good thing is in chess
you know
each exactly what they do like if I move
my pawn then the new board configuration
will be the pawn will no longer be here
but here right so you know exactly
what's going to happen you can calculate
that your perfect simulator then other
domains you don't have that for example
in Atari all you have in Atari is this
this screen right maybe you have a
little little submarine here right you
have some opponents right the opponent I
don't know what are the opponents look
like fish I don't even know in this game
right and you can I think you can shoot
there just coins to select I don't know
okay in any case and sometimes you need
to go up and there is like a health bar
so but but in essence you only have this
this this screen here right you don't
have you don't have more and if if you
press a button you can you can you don't
exactly know what's going to happen you
don't exactly know what the pixel space
will look like as this shot moves
forward right I guess you could know but
you can't you can't use that to plan
because the kind of space is too big and
your actions maybe no not clearly
predictable and when you win aren't
clearly predictable and there may be
randomness so all of this stuff usually
when people do is here they do use a
model free reinforcement learning we've
had this discussion
you know before so this would be model
free and while chess here you'd go about
model based now mu zero does is it uses
a model based planning but it learns the
model so it tries to construct a model
for this here it tries to say okay if I
have the screen a here right my thing is
here and I press the button
right then probably my submarine is
going to be a bit more to the right but
it doesn't do this exactly so this has
been done before and this is what's
what's kind of known as learning an
environment model where you map current
environment plus action to the next step
in the environment right and this
usually doesn't work too well because
you're really trying to generate this
entire pixel space here what the cool
thing about New 0 is it doesn't do that
it doesn't predict the next state what
it does predict is a hidden state and
let's draw the hidden state there's a
little cloud here it predicts a hidden
state of the next state and from the
hidden state it will predict things like
the reward the policy the value and then
it can use from that hidden state ill
predict the next hidden state you and
from that it will again predict the
reward so the base idea is you only
predict you only predict what you
absolutely need to obtain the values
that are important for doing
reinforcement learning you're not trying
to predict the fall environment you're
simply trying to predict whatever is
necessary and this here is a learned
quantity whatever is necessary to
predict what what your what your RL
model is going to need so that's that's
the basic gist of it and we'll look at
how they do it or how they describe what
they're doing so basically the picture a
here is how mu 0 plans so imagine you
have a configuration in the current
state this is an observation and this
could be a chess board this could also
be a position in shogi but it could also
be a screen in an Atari game or a camera
input of a self-driving car and so on
and the first thing it does it encodes
that observation using this H
um I believe they call this a
representation function you can code
that to this hidden state another hidden
State
this is appropriately sized the hidden
state here is supposed to capture
everything you need about the state to
predict the kind of RL quantities in the
future right and you learn this function
H which in this case of course is going
to be a neural network in order to
produce such a state now from this state
you do two things first of all you have
this function f here and they call this
the I I don't remember but you have a
function to predict the following two
quantities you predict the value
function at that state and the value
function simply means if you are in this
state here right and this is now another
true state but a hidden state but still
if you're in this state in this hidden
state that belongs to this observation
then in the future you're going to make
this much reward on average right with
your current policy that's the value
function so the value function basically
tells you how good it is to be in a
given state right and then the policy
this is a bit special the policy is
predicting how you would act in this
state now this is a bit a bit confusing
or it was to me when I first learned it
because we're going to see over here how
I'll amuse zero decides on how to act
namely it does this entire tree search
thing up to a certain depth right and
then it creates this histogram and from
that it produces the action but in order
to produce to do this tree search this
is exactly this picture a this is the
that tree search that is done and in
order to do that you need these P values
because we'll go there in a second you
need these P values and they cannot
themselves
again do it research right that would be
like infinite recursion so what you need
is you need kind of an estimate right
like if I were and especially down down
for it makes more sense if I were in
that state how would I act right if I
were to do a tree search like this so
you simply build a neural network that
tells you with one evaluation without
having to do the entire tree search down
from here how you would act this doesn't
need to be a perfect approximation of
how you would actually act but it needs
to be good enough right so this simply
tells you how you would act in that
state and that's important because what
we do next is we use this policy to
generate this action and this is a
simulated action this isn't a real
action because the real action would go
here to the next actual observation this
is a simulated action saying if I'm in
this hidden state right my policy
approximately would be this thing and so
I can sample from that and say my action
in that state would be this action and
so now I have a hidden state and an
action and from that I can produce the
next hidden State
now of course if I were to apply the
action up here to the observation right
action one I would get the next
observation and that is exactly how
alpha zero works right you use your
simulator your perfect simulator to take
the current observation the current
state with a given action that your this
policy gives you and you produce the
next state but we don't have a perfect
simulator right and we don't want to
learn a model that predicts the entire
state but what we want to do is we want
to predict the following if we were to
take a 1 here if right we would get an
observation can we predict the result
when we would apply the function H to
that right giving me a
Prime right this is observation prime so
this function age here which is the
function that map's from observation
space to hidden space if we were to
apply this to the next to the next
observation we would obtain some hidden
state for that observation can we
predict that thing so we need a function
that maps from the hidden state given an
action right to the next hidden state
and that's exactly what what happens
down here right this function G here
Maps exactly this hidden state plus the
action to the next hidden state and also
also at the same time it will predict a
reward right because in each step you
might get a reward so each transition
here gives you a reward and we're trying
to predict that as well not that
important especially for games like
chess or shogi where there's only win or
lose at the very end but they
incorporate this here to also be able to
play these Atari games and like a
broader range of reinforcement learning
games but in essence that's what it is
right we're trying to predict the next
hidden state and now we can basically
recursively apply this so from here I
have an idea of what my policy might be
in that state right my approximate
policy my kind of a mini policy that
only needs one evaluation I can sample
an action from that policy and if maybe
it's action to here and I can then
predict the next hidden state that I
would be in also the reward right and
therefore using this I can do like a
tree search so I can simulate future
trajectories right first like all of
these policies I can sample from them an
example from them gives a giving me
different actions so that that'll lead
me down the tree different routes so I
can simulate future trajectories in this
tree
and at the end I have a pretty good idea
I can do this up to a certain depth
right I don't have to do it until the
very end I can and then I'll have a
pretty good idea of how my immediate the
immediate future looks right which
actions lead me to approximately which
states and for each state of course
especially for each bottom state here I
have an estimation of the value of that
state so basically I can the easiest
thing would simply be to whatever search
how many steps is this one now this is 0
1 2 3 steps into the future and for each
of these states obtain the value V here
V here V V V V then I simply pick the
action up the action up here I'm running
out of colors and simply pick the action
up here that will lead me eventually to
the highest value state so that's we of
course we've not cooperated opponent
plays here and so on but that's the
basic idea you can do this more
sophisticated this um tree search and
this is a topic that we might cover in a
video about alphago or 4-0 but in
essence you can do the same thing as
alphago or alpha zero except if you're
not working with the simulator but
you're working with a learned model on
the hidden states of the true
observations so B is how you would
actually act right so for each
observation here we'd say you'd run such
a tree search and you kind of get a
histogram over visited actions and again
we'll skip over that here but this this
is part of the alpha zero paper and you
decide on an action and that will give
you a reward and a next observation and
that's how you act and then you train
these things end to end so you you train
you train the networks such that of
course the reward you know
the rewards are right the reward
prediction of gee you know what that
should be
right from given a trajectory and action
sequence
you know what the individual reward
should be sure that's you can train gee
for that first of all you can also train
to predict the correct value functions
like in classic reinforcement learning
you can do like an N step into the
future prediction or you can play until
the end sample trajectories and so on
and the policy you predict you you
predict the policy your approximate
policy to match your true actions right
because your true actions you've
generated by doing this entire tree
search thing which is you know that
you're what you're actually going to do
so you're training your approximate
policy predictor that you use to run the
tree search to match as close as
possible to your actual actions write
this in this fashion so this policy
resulting from hidden state zero should
be as close as possible to the action
you actually took in the observation
that led to hidden state zero yeah so
this is how you search search act and
train using mu zero and this is pretty
this is it right this is the rest is as
experiments the rest is simply showing
that they can handle these games they
can keep the performance basically off
the simulator based alpha zero in in
games sorry where are the results here
yeah so in these games in these left
hand games they can keep the performance
of alpha zero even exceeded here in go
and remember they don't have a simulator
like alpha zero they have to learn this
model and in Atari they actually
out compete the current state of the art
which is I think r2d2 or Impala but it's
it's some model I guess some model free
RL baseline here on the on Atari so
that's pretty cool and I think that
brings RL to kind of a new level with
this hidden learning and yeah date so
they compared against against multiple
once although r2d2 is a different thing
alright yeah
so that's that's that me it's a cool
paper it's short read it if you if you
want I invite you to also look at the
additional experiments where they
basically oblate what they need is the
learned model really as good or better
as the real simulator does it take as
much time actually takes less time which
for higher elo
which is pretty cool how many
simulations are needed things like this
alright that was it I like this paper
check it out